what are the options that you guys offer
for freezing just so i know for the
cryonics process at alcor that's your
company alcor and what what what are the
the options like what's the packages
i should say by when you say my company
it's actually a non-profit organization
we're a 501c texas a non-profit
organization okay and that's important
to us because as a profit-making company
i've got nothing against that but it
tends to not survive very long if you
look at them historically whereas
non-profits educational organizations
religious organizations they can survive
for centuries that's why we're set up
that way so we nobody actually makes
profits from this we you know we have
salary stuff but of course nobody makes
profits it's fact well it i love that
man it's fascinating because yeah i mean
you guys are basically like um like
death like magellan's i mean you guys
are out there just like you know that's
that's a good analogy i think that's a
good analogy because when people say
well what kind of people do this
um well there are a number of factors
but one of them that's really critical
is you have to be an explorer i mean if
you think about i've talked to so many
people about this and uh those who say
well yeah i can i can see how this could
work this is not implausible and then
they go but oh my god this might work
that's that's scary because they think
about coming back into a future maybe
100 years from now everything's
radically different their skills are
outdated they don't know anybody and it
horrifies them yeah which i think is one
big reason why there aren't more people
doing this uh it tends to appeal to
people who have you know a magellan type
personality and explorer personality who
look on that and say well yeah it's
gonna take some getting used to although
the organization part of its mission is
to help you get you know rehabilitated
yeah you got to be brave because you're
going to go see your buddy and he's
going to be like 70 years older
or you're going to go so he's going to
be gone all your like a lot of your
friends might be gone or say if you died
at like 21 and you got froze and you
come back 40 years later you're going to
go over to your friend's house he's
going to be 60 you know it's like
everything's going to be
actually probably not that because
again the technology we're talking about
to to reverse all the damage that's been
done by that point that you've legally
died plus the extra damage done in the
process we will fix the aging problem
before we bring people back so at least
your friend yeah they may be 80 years
older but they won't look 80 years older
but yeah they'll still been that huge
gap in experience obviously
now it's better if you can persuade your
friends and family to come with you yeah
yeah i know quite a few people i know a
number of people already cry preserved
and i have my wife has signed up for
this and a lot of my friends are so i
don't have that problem so much i know
some people but not everybody will
but you know i'd still rather come back
not knowing anybody i mean i came from i
came from england to los angeles back in
the 80s and i didn't really know anybody
and and it was a weird place here you
had this kind of bright object shining
from the sky instead of waterfalling on
me which was what's up with that people
driving on the road people driving on
the wrong side of the road and stuff but
we came over here yeah in the 1700s and
we didn't know anybody yeah you know
um exactly it's like a journey through
time instead of a journey through space
dude that's so there's so many things
going on here man so
but also you're going to bring your wife
bro that's a risky move huh
why is that risky i mean i think it's
great i think it's very honorable and
it's very it's it's very sweet and kind
but what if like dude you know
it just see you got to really be dialed
in for a lo you know because you only
said what for like what is the vow it's
like oh we didn't do that one though oh
it's till death to us part you should
have said until legal death do us part
yeah we didn't do that one because we
have a problem with the idea of death so
no it does bring up some interesting
questions because yeah i mean okay
you've got 50 years together 70 years
ago okay but what about a thousand years
together
so but you know we'll worry about that
warning yeah
yeah that's a good call
so yeah you have to think of these
people yeah because you
i think in the simplistic mind
which i happen to possess thankfully for
the both of us um it's you just think
like the the and the animal the the the
neanderthal thoughts are like i'm gonna
live forever
uh i'm gonna come back but you don't
think about after that like do you
like what do you guys do do you guys
just give them like a bus ticket like
out of prison or whatever do you guys
like like what where where do you put
them at is there like a re-entry program
uh yes or no i mean
no in the sense that this is still so
far off that we can't really we can't
really figure out we don't even know who
will make the decision to bring you back
i mean will it be our organization will
it be some kind of you know
ethics panel of universities or a
government thing we don't we don't even
know that right so we can't really plan
in too much detail but yes we do think
about it and we it's part of our mission
statement you go to the website look at
our mission statement part of that is
not just to wake you up kind of shove
you out the door and say good luck man
no we're going to actually rehabilitate
you yeah here's a hand warmer yeah
exactly uh yeah when today think about
it today there are people who've been in
comas for years even decades uh if you
have seen the movie awakenings with
robert de niro i just watched that movie
a couple of months ago can we bring some
of that up
that's fascinating yeah based on on on
the book by oliver sax so these are
people who are basically uh in a special
kind of coma basically their dopamine
levels in the brain were really low they
were like frozen statues not really
aware of the passage of time some of
them like that for more than more than a
decade or two and when they were woken
up um of course for some of them it was
pretty horrifying because they had
suddenly aged overnight uh yeah so like
that an hour okay it'll be the opposite
of that uh because you look in the
mirror and go damn i look good yeah yeah
yeah
right because
people would be excited because you
would be bringing them back in so what
you're saying is you're going to be
bringing people back into their best
self exactly because that's technology
that'll help because you'll come back
not feeling crappy like when you when
you cease to function you'll come back
feeling the best self plus we are there
to help you out we're going to
rehabilitate whatever that will mean at
the time it might mean um you know we're
going to put you in some virtual reality
environment to sort of train how the
world works before you step out in front
of that flying car or whatever you know
uh we don't really know what things
would be like a hundred years from now
nobody does anybody who says they do is
lying because you just can't forecast
that far ahead yeah future people if
somebody says they're from the future
brother probably lying
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one